ein astronaut oder eine astronautin
erkrankt im weltraum im gegensatz zur
erde kann dass dort sehr schnell
lebensgefährlich werden
ein krankenhaus gibt es nicht und die
möglichkeiten zur behandlung sind
eingeschränkt aber vor allem die auch
der diagnose doch jetzt ist es einem
forschungsteam der nasa gelungen
bakterien direkt mit einem test an bord
zu identifizieren das ist wirklich eine
sensation und ein riesenfortschritt er
durch dieses spannende thema whatsapp
gewünschte bekommen wir jetzt alle
wichtigen facts dazu und vor allem wie
der hurrikan habe das unterfangen fast
gestoppt hätte und was das für das
außerirdische leben und dessen
entdeckung bedeutet jetzt den blick zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
einen themenvorschlag über whatsapp bzw
die anderen messenger vielen dank dafür
wie er da dabei sein könnt und themen
vorschlagen und vor allem die
unzuverlässige abo box von youtube
überlisten könnte das erfahrt ihr am
ende des videos
es könnten milliarden ja sogar billionen
von mikroben sein die sich an bord der
iss der internationalen raumstation
tummeln und wie hier auf der erde können
die bakterien uns menschen krank machen
doch im all ist eine erkrankung
natürlich noch einmal eine verschärfte
situation denn hier kann medizinische
hilfe anders als auf der erde nicht in
vollem umfang gewährleistet werden
deswegen dürften forschung zu weltweit
schon länger daran tests zu entwickeln
mit denen sich proben direkt vor ort
analysieren lassen
krankheiten könnten besser und vor allem
schneller diagnostiziert werden und
zudem könnte so auch einfach erforscht
werden wie die mikroben mit der
schwerelosigkeit im all zu recht kommt
bislang mussten die proben tatsächlich
zur erde in entsprechende labore
gebracht werden eine aufwendige und
kostenintensive und vor allen dingen
langwierige sache ja und stellt euch mal
vor setzt außerirdische lebewesen können
so direkt vor ort analysiert werden ein
forschungsteam der nasa ist es jetzt
tatsächlich gelungen
solch eine möglichkeit zu entwickeln
herausgekommen ist ein zweistufiger
prozess mit dem namen jeans in space
free der mittlerweile auch bereits in
der praxis umgesetzt werden konnte und
zwar auf der uss dazu sammelten die
beteiligten forscherinnen und forscher
zunächst von verschiedenen oberflächen
der raumstation proben und gaben sie in
petrischalen durch den zusatz an der
nährlösung konnten sie die mikroben
vermehren in einem weiteren schritt
isolierte das forschungsteam deren
erbsubstanz mit hilfe der sogenannten
polymerasekettenreaktion die kennt ihr
vielleicht noch aus dem chemieunterricht
vervielfältigten sie die dna der zweite
schritt des prozesses wurde von peggy
weit durchgeführt vielleicht habt ihr
ihren namen schon mal gehört sie ist
rekord astronautin und tatsächlich die
frau weltweit die die längste zeit im
weltraum verbracht hat die biochemikerin
schaute sich das erbgut also genauer an
und erstellte eine sogenannte sequenz
analyse dadurch lassen sich
charakteristische abschnitte der dna
also dass erbgutes identifizieren
und so feststellen um welchen organismus
es sich handelt als wichtigstes
instrument dient ihr dabei ein mini e on
ein tragbarer sequenziert automat gerade
mal so groß wie ein handy
zitat sofort haben wir gesehen dass ein
mikroorganismus auftaucht und dann noch
ein zweiter und so weiter sagt eine der
beteiligten forscherinnen sarah wallace
dieser ganze prozess fand tatsächlich
komplett an bord der uss also im
weltraum stadt absolute premiere und
sensationen und zwar nicht einfach weil
die astronautin sally ride bei dem
komplizierten verfahren vom boden aus
geführt werden musste doch es sollte
spannend bleiben denn unvorhersehbare
geschehnisse bedrohten den erfolg des
projektes allerdings kurioserweise nicht
im all sondern auf der erde konkret ging
es um den hurrikan herr w
der hochwasser und gefährliche
straßenverhältnisse mit sich brachte so
war das team das pegi weit im all
unterstützte gezwungen eine zeitlang auf
die persönlichen handys zurückzugreifen
und so hilfestellung an die iss zu
übermitteln doch die analysen liefen
fehlerfrei und konnten später in laboren
auf der erde sogar mehrfach bestätigt
werden jetzt können damit in zukunft in
raumschiffen aber auch außerirdische
organismen untersucht und identifiziert
werden ein riesenfortschritt für die
wissenschaft wenn ihr kein video zur
entdeckung von außerirdischen deren
entdeckung vermutet die nasa schon bald
und zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp und
den anderen messengern nur dann verpasst
er kein video denn die abo box auf
youtube wisst ihr ja diese immer
ziemlich lückenhaft über den messenger
erfahrt ihr von mir land vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines
goodie für euch am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal kriegs um social and
media abonnieren da erfahrt ihr das
neueste aus der social media welt dafür
hier klicken und natürlich nicht achtung
genau die glocke vergessen wie geht s
weiter dafür auf draufklicken aliens der
erste kontakt ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran